-You know our first guest
tonight from his work
in such films as "The Hangover"
and "Crazy Rich Asians."
He stars in the new special
"Ken Jeong Cracks Christmas,"
which debuts on Buzzfeed's
YouTube channel December 12th.
Let's take a look.
-Can I sit on your left knee?
-Sure.
-I won't lie to you,
I haven't worked out in a while.
I don't want to hurt your knee.
-No, you'll be all right.
You'll be all right.
-I can plant my feet.
-You're all right, there.
You're all right.
-Maybe just to --
-So, you've been pretty good,
huh?
-Not really.
-Yeah, I know.
This is the happiest I've been
since "Crazy Rich Asians"
hit the top of the charts.
-Please welcome back to the
show, Ken Jeong, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Welcome back.
-Thank you.
-It's wonderful
to have you here.
-Wonderful to be back.
-So, this -- you were --
Was that a Santa School
you were at?
-Yeah. That was a Santa School
in Midland, Michigan.
And it's 500
Santa Students learning, like,
in-depth character analysis
about being Santa Claus.
No joke.
It's almost like --
It is kind of like
watching Ed Norton
dissect a character in a play
or something.
-And this is, I'm assuming,
to then be a Santa at a mall?
-Santa -- Yes.
Yeah, these are at level 1,
mall-level Santas.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-I mean,
I will say I'm happy to hear
that level 1 mall Santas
take it that seriously.
-Oh, yeah,
it's like Meisner for Santas.
-Gotcha. Was there anything
you learned there
that wouldn't be sort of what
you would expect to learn there?
-Yeah. They would go,
"Okay, I'm from the North Pole,"
and the principal is like
"Where in the North Pole?"
You know, like, "I don't know.
A cul-de-sac or something?"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You know, and then,
"Oh, you know, my wife..."
"How long you been married
to Mrs. Claus?"
I mean, all these little things
that none of these kids
would ever give a crap about.
-Yeah.
It seems that they think that
they're gonna be cross-examined
when I feel like most kids want
to talk about themselves
more than they want to find out
where Santa is from.
-They're like,
"Can you just give me the Xbox?"
-Yeah.
-You know, that kind of...
-They're like, "Hey, Santa,
I didn't come here
for your back story."
-Yeah, right.
"I'm not tiny Stanislavski."
-But this entire special
is you going around
and talking to different people
about holiday traditions.
-Yeah. It's been great.
I've never done anything
like that before,
just kind of
going across the country.
What I loved
about the Santa School,
some of the backstories
are really incredible.
Like, you meet retired people
who maybe quit their job
because of a health scare,
or maybe a heart attack,
and they have another calling.
And I'm like, "So, when did you
choose to be Santa?"
And they take it that seriously.
And I mean this
in a non-ironic way.
It's like, "No, Santa chose me."
They have that kind of --
It's so cute!
-That's nice to hear.
-It's really nice to hear that.
Yeah, it was really --
-I mean, it's certainly nicer
than like, "I'm just in it
for the cash, man."
-Yeah.
"Two words -- booze and chicks,
you know?"
[ Laughter ]
-What percentage of them
have the real beard,
and how many are fake beards?
Do you see a lot of real ones?
-100%.
-100% were real?
-Real beards, yeah.
-This is the Harvard
of Santa Schools.
-Yes, Harvard, yeah, yeah.
-That's great.
-It's pretty amazing.
-You mentioned in the clip,
as well,
and I want to congratulate you,
"Crazy Rich Asians."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-I can only imagine how --
It must have been
so exciting to film,
and then the reaction to it
and the success of it
must just be
an incredible post-script.
-It's the only movie
I've ever been a part of --
Usually when you do
Hollywood studio movies, like,
"What's in it for me?
How do I get next level?"
And this is the only movie
I've ever done
where I'm happier for my cast
and my friends on the movie
and also for the Asian-American
community, in general,
because I have
so many friends --
Asian-American friends
way more talented than me
who are filmmakers,
writers, directors.
They're getting their projects
green-lit in Hollywood
that have predominately
Asian-American casts,
and now they're seeing that it's
financially feasible to do this.
I've never seen anything
like this in my career.
And now that I have
two daughters, you know,
11-year-old daughters and they
have these amazing role models
like Awkwafina and Gemma Chan
and Constance Wu
and Michelle Yeoh, to me,
it's been such a game-changer
for our community
just because it actually
transcended our community.
-Well, congrats.
It really was something,
and it was great to watch.
-Thank you so much.
-And it was -- the film itself,
nominated for a Golden Globe,
and then Constance Wu
which is really exciting.
-Yeah, never in a million years
we thought this would be
up for Golden Globes
or Critics' Choice awards.
So we're really
in the middle of it.
I just texted Jon Chu,
the director
of "Crazy Rich Asians,"
and he literally said, "Insane."
Like, that's all he was saying.
It's really nice.
-Another awards show right now,
the Oscars,
they do not have a host.
I don't know
if you've heard this.
There have been some articles
written that suggest
one of the names
that have come up
is a very funny person
who would maybe be a good fit...
-Hmm.
-is you, Ken.
-Mm.
Now, Ken...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...tell us.
Tell us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh.
Looks ready.
-He looks very ready.
-I was always taught
that when you set goals,
make sure you keep them
very high.
-Yeah.
-If I do not become
the host of the Oscars, I will
consider not only my career
but my life a failure.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Any goal
that's out of your control...
-Yeah, that's what you need
to marry yourself to.
-...that doesn't really make
sense whether you do it or not.
-Yeah.
-I want it so bad.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you think?
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's always that risk.
-There's always that risk.
-When you want something
that bad, you might come out --
if you do it, you might come out
and look a little desperate,
and then the audience
will get nervous.
-Seth, my whole career
is desperate.
[ Laughter ]
Seth, that is my brand.
I came out of the womb,
it was like, "Hello!"
[ Laughter ]